I'm going to show you mathematically
what's happening in here. Are you ready?
Hello world.
It's Saroj and the brain.
It's deeply influenced so much machine
learning theory and in this video I'm
going to take a little bit of a different
approach to my usual lectures and
introduce four unique machine learning
algorithms in the context of both human
and animal learning.
Ultimately using one of them to train
a digital mouse to find the exit in a
maze.
If you're new here,
hit subscribe to stay updated
with my latest content.
I'm going to constantly be pushing
educational videos to this channel every
single week.
In the early 20th century,
a physiologist named Ivan Pavlov was
studying the physiology of the gestion in
dogs in the lab.
He noticed that his dogs begin to salivate
in the presence of the technician who
normally fed them rather than only
salivating in the presence of food.
Pavlov was inspired by this informal
observation to conduct a more formal
experiment.
He presented an audio stimuli to a dog,
then gave it food.
He did this a few times and then
when the dog heard the sound,
even without the food, it started
salivating. That beat must've been fired.
He concluded that if a particular stimulus
in the dog surroundings was present
when the dog was given food,
then that stimulus could become associated
with food and cause salvation on its
own.
Due to this positive reinforcement loop.
This experiments popularly called Pavlov's
dog experiment helped form the basis
for associative learning theory.
It describes the process by which a
person or animal learns an association
between two Stimuli.
The basic claims of
associative learning theory,
our that reinforcement learning is the
acquisition of associations between
states' actions and rewards.
The animal is acquiring these associations
through learning. In this case,
we can assume the state to be a stimulus.
It's useful for predicting
the potential reward.
It also claims that the modifications
of these associations are driven I
prediction errors.
That means the discrepancy between what
the animal expected to get and what it
actually got.
The most influential idea of associative
learning theory was invented by two
researchers named rescore law and Wagner.
A couple decades later.
They're model is a prediction error
based learning model in which stimuli
acquire value.
When there is a mismatch
between the prediction and
the outcome in the equation.
The value of stimulus s at trial t is
set equal to the value of stimulus s at
the previous time step plus
the reward and the expectation.
The learning rate defines how much
this prediction error is weighted.
This prediction error says that when
the animal gets more reward than it
expected,
it leads to strengthening
of the associative weights
and a negative prediction
error leads to a weakening
of the associative weights.
The risk score La Wagner model was
groundbreaking for two reasons.
The first reason is that it was able to
explain a huge number of phenomena in
fear conditioning.
Using that model,
researchers were able to map out
the detailed structure of how these
computations could be implemented
by a Mig Dulles circuitry.
The second reason is that it helped
developed some early natural language
processing applications
like part of speech tagging.
I'm sure they could have named it
something more descriptive, but hey,
it was the 70s but wild.
The risk score low walked her model
provided a basis for associative learning
theory. It only estimated a
single value. We know however,
that biological brains are
able to represent uncertainty
about the world somehow
since the world is full of uncertainty,
probability theory suggests that to
properly represent a biological brains
uncertainty of the world,
it should utilize a probability
distribution over the
possible weights instead
of a single value.
We can use a famous statistical rule
invented by Thomas Bayes called never talk
about fight club. Wait, that's
something else. It's called Bayes rule.
It states that the posterior probability,
which is the probability that the
hypothesis is true is equal to the prior
probability,
which is how well the hypothesis fits
existing knowledge multiplied by the
likelihood of the evidence.
If the hypothesis is true
divided by the prior probability,
that the evidence itself is true where
the evidence is a description of how well
the hypothesis explains the new evidence.
Another way of saying this is that the
probability of event a occurring given
that be as true is equal to
the probability of B occurring.
Given that a is true multiplied by the
independent probability of a divided by
the independent probability
of B, the Basie and
generalization of the risk score.
Low Wagner model is embodied in
what's called the Coleman filter.
It states that uncertainty grows over
time due to the random diffusion of the
weights.
It also states that this uncertainty
can be reduced by observing the data.
It uses a series of measurements observed
over time and produce his estimates of
unknown variables that tend to be more
accurate than those based on a single
measurement alone by estimating a
joint probability distribution over the
variables for each timeframe.
The common filter has numerous
applications in technology
including navigation
and control of vehicles like
Aircrafts sell flying planes. Yup.
It's also applied in time
series analysis and robotics.
It works by modeling the central nervous
system's control of movement because of
the time delay between issuing motor
commands and receiving sensory feedback.
The common filter is a realistic model
for making estimates of the current state
of a motor system and using commands.
It's a two step process
in the predictions step.
It produces estimates of the current
state variables along with their
uncertainties. Once the outcome of
the next measurement is observed,
these estimates are updated
using a weighted average
with the most weight given
to estimates with higher certainty.
It's a recursive real time algorithm
using just the present input measurements
and the previously calculated state
as well as its uncertainty matrix.
So far we've broken
down tasks into trials,
but real life operates in continuous
time and our algorithms are short
shortsighted. They've only been able
to predict the immediate reward,
the one that will be received in the very
next state to extend the capabilities
of what we're able to
model mathematically.
Let's switch from classical learning
theory to modern reinforcement learning
theory with a focus on a specific
sequential decision problem.
A mouse trying to find the exit
in a maze full of fire. Nevermind.
There are two popular classes
of reinforcement learning
algorithms we can use to
help solve this problem.
The first art model free techniques,
these attempt to build
up a table of values.
The value is the cumulative future
award at the animal expects to get when
performing a particular action.
In a particular state.
The idea here is that we are not building
an explicit internal model of the
world.
Instead,
it were directly trying to estimate
a lookup table from trial and error.
Once we have the lookup table,
we can use it to choose the optimal
action for any particular state.
The other strategy is
model based learning.
The idea is that the animal will
construct an internal model of the world.
That means two things. First, it
will learn a transition function,
meaning if it's in a particular
state and it takes an action,
what's going to be the next
state and to a reward function,
which estimates how much reward it
expects to get in any particular state.
We can use dynamic programming here
or a variety of algorithms to simulate
different paths in the environment and
pick actions that lead us to the optimal
path.
Both of these algorithms have trade offs.
The model free system is fast.
We just perform a table look up,
but it's inflexible.
If the reward function changes.
All the values in the
lookup table have to change.
Whereas in the model based learning
system, it's more flexible.
If the reward at some state changes,
we just change the reward function at
that state and that reward will propagate
to all of our values via the
reward function we've defined,
but it's slower.
A model free learning technique
called a temporal difference.
Learning extended the risk score la
Wagner model by introducing a discount
factor into the prediction error,
which helps define how much
a reward matters to an agent.
Depending on when in time it's received,
meaning we can make rewards that
happen in the near term worth more.
It was invented by two researchers
named son and Barto in the late eighties
while they wrote their defining work,
an introduction to reinforcement learning.
Unfortunately,
no one really cared much for TD learning
until a paper came out in the late
nineties a decade later,
which showed that the temporal difference
model could accurately represent
dopamine response in the brain.
That's dope.
If we just represent a reward by
itself without any cues just to reward,
we'll see a burst of dopamine neurons.
However,
if that reward is predicted by some cue,
so the Q reliably predicts a reward,
we won't see a dopamine burst in
response to the reward. Instead,
we'll see a dopamine burst as a response
to the queue that predicted that
reward.
This contradicts the popular view
of dopamine as a reward molecule.
If it was just reporting reward,
then we'd expect it to respond
when reward was delivered,
regardless of whether that reward
was predicted or not. And in fact,
it only responds to unpredicted
rewards when reward is surprising,
the TD model helps explain
why that's happens.
Once the reward is fully predicted,
there will no longer be
any prediction error.
And the dopamine response is reporting
these prediction errors from the model.
It's been used to create game bots that
can be humans most popularly by deep
mind and it's deep cue learning
algorithm able to beat many Atari Games.
Td learning helps capture some important
properties of temporal dynamics as well
as dopamine responses,
but it lacks the uncertainty tracking
mechanism of the common filter.
So we need a Basie and
version of TD learning and we
can call that the coal mine
TD instead of just estimating
a single value of the weights.
We're estimating amine and covariance
matrix for the weights of our model.
We can think of all four of these models
along two dimensions based on what kind
of estimate or they are either
Bayesean or point based,
and what the target they're trying to
estimate is either immediate reward or
value. Here are the three points
to remember from this video.
Associative learning is a learning
process in which a new response becomes
associated with a particular stimulus.
When we build mathematical
models of learning,
we can use distributions instead of single
values to help represent uncertainty
about the world.
And Tim poral difference learning is
a model free learning technique that
predicts the expected value of a variable
occurring at the end of a sequence of
states.
You're good looking and smart a plus
for making it to the end of this video.
Hit subscribe and I'll give you an a plus.
Plus for now,
I've got to chase a reward,
so thanks for watching.